-Welcome back to the show.
We love having you here.
And, gosh, I got real
competitive with that game,
and I apologize.
-So did I.
I think it's fair to say
that "Zimmy" won.
Jimmy and Zoey together.
Don't you think?
-I'll take a win for Zimmy
anytime.
-I think --
I think you gave that to me.
-Can I just say how excited
I am that you're here?
Because I'm talking to a star of
the Marvel cinematic universe.
-Are you? [ Laughs ]
-Yes. Do you know that?
-I -- Well, okay. I was in --
Well, I played
girl in the bathroom
who got attacked by the lizard
coming out of the toilet
in "The Amazing Spider-Man."
I'm sure you guys
all saw me in that, right?
-Of course. We loved it.
That was our favorite --
-Yeah, well, maybe there
wasn't an immediate clap
because I was actually credited
as "Gossip Girl,"
so maybe that's maybe more of
what you recognized me as.
[ Laughter ]
But I was in one scene.
-Was Andrew Garfield
in it with you?
-Yes, Andrew Garfield --
No, he wasn't in the scene.
-No, of course not.
-No, just...
-I was just testing you
to see if you remember it.
-I remembered it. Yeah.
I was in one scene.
I had no lines.
I was so excited.
And for whatever reason,
they used that scene
as the, like, teaser
at Comic-Con.
And so people thought
I had a big part
and kept saying to me like,
"Oh, my God, you're the star of
'The Amazing Spider-Man.'
I didn't know
that you're the star
of 'The Amazing Spider-Man.'"
It's like, "I didn't either."
But I went to the theaters,
and I was cut out of the movie.
So it doesn't really
have a happy ending.
But I think technically,
I'm in the MCU.
I'm, like, in the
black-hole part of the MCU.
-Yeah, you were cut out
of the film, unfortunately,
so no one got to see it.
-I have not seen it.
-But I have friends
in high places.
[ laughter ]
I got the clip.
-I actually really
haven't seen this,
so I don't know how you...
-Actually -- No, really.
We have the clip.
I'm gonna show it to you.
Also, I want to have
the camera on you
'cause I want
to see your reaction.
I will say the visual effects
are not quite there
because it actually
was cut out of the film.
But this is Zoey Deutch
in "The Amazing Spider-Man."
Let's take a look at this.
The debut.
♪♪
-Oh, my gosh.
-There you go.
♪♪
-Wow.
Oh, my God. Yikes.
♪♪
[ Both scream ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow. That is unbelievable.
-Really?
-Yeah, I loved it.
-It feels like --
Wow. That was interesting.
-I loved it.
-CGI has gotten a lot better
in the last ten years.
And I hope my acting, too.
That was...
"Aah!" Horrifying.
-You've been acting
for over a decade.
Did you always know
you wanted to be an actor?
-I think so. But -- I think so.
Yeah, I've always
been loud and annoying.
But I accidentally found
the exact moment, I think,
that I claimed
that this was my path
that I wanted to go down.
There was an interview
20 years ago with my mom,
who's also an actress,
and the interviewer asked her
if she thinks her kids
want to be actors one day.
And so I brought the video
for you. There you go.
-I appreciate that.
Your mom is the one and only
Lea Thompson, by the way,
who is amazing.
[ Applause ]
This is...
This is Lea Thompson
being interviewed 20 years ago.
Take a look at this.
-So, Lea, does either daughter
have any interest
in acting or anything so far?
-I want to.
I really want to be an actress.
-Oh, well, that's the first time
I've heard of that.
Oh, you want to be an actress?
-Yeah.
-'Cause you see
how glamorous it is?
-No!
-[ Laughs ]
-Well, that's part of it.
-Yeah. Oh. Come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That is part of it.
-Oh, my gosh.
How cute is that? Come on.
It's only part of it.
So charming.
Your new movie --
"Not Okay," by the way,
is the name of the movie.
-Are you okay?
-I'm okay.
-You guys okay?
-Yeah, we're okay.
-Everyone's okay?
-But in this movie,
your character tells a lie
that gets out of hand.
Are you a good liar
in real life?
-I don't know. Am I?
No, I'm a good liar.
But then I have to immediately
confess like I just did.
And I did in the video, too.
I say like, "No!"
-You can't help.
-I can't help it.
-But you're good at --
I heard you're good at telling
if someone is telling a lie.
-My sister says that
I'm a human lie detector.
But I don't know.
I don't know.
-I want to challenge you
to maybe a game of
"Two Truths and a Lie"
if that's okay with you.
-Okay.
-Alright?
-On your card here is two truths
about you and a lie.
I don't know.
And I have mine here.
Okay. I have here.
So maybe you read yours first.
Two of these are true
and one is a lie.
And I'm gonna see
if I can guess yours.
-[ Clears throat ]
In a span of two years...
-That's a lie.
-...I got stuck in three
different elevators.
-[ Laughs ]
I took -- Do you want to ask me
questions, or shall I continue?
-Do I ask questions?
-I don't know. If you want to.
-Huh. I think
you're being too forward.
I think it's true.
-Okay.
I took my pet beetle with me
to school for a month.
[ Laughter ]
-A pet beetle?
-Beetle Fren.
-What's his name?
-Beetle Fren. F-R-E-N.
-Beetle Fren?
-Yeah.
-That makes me believe
that it's true,
but how could you invent
the name Beetle Fren?
It's really cute.
Okay. Beetle Fren.
Do you miss Beetle Fren?
-Well, he was always dead.
-Okay. Alright.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my gosh.
Your pet was always dead.
Alright.
-It was always dead.
-Okay.
-I once peed my pants
on Robert De Niro's plane.
[ Laughter ]
-Now, are you sure
this is not my truth?
[ Laughter ]
-They mixed up the cards?
-Hmm.
Wow. You peed your pants
on Robert De Niro's plane.
I feel like maybe you were
a baby or something,
and you might have done that.
-Why was I on --
Why would I be...
-Well...
Gosh.
What was the first one again?
It was stuck in three elevators?
-In the span of two years,
I got stuck in
three different elevators.
What do you guys think?
-I think the first one is a lie.
[ Drumroll ]
-Unfortunately,
you are wrong, Jimmy.
[ Buzzer ]
-Do you get to tell me which --
-Yeah.
-You did stuck in an elevator?
-No, I didn't take my pet beetle
with me to school for a month.
I had a pet beetle,
but I didn't take him to school,
so I'm sorry.
-That's a -- Come on!
You tricked me.
-Well, that's the game.
I'm supposed to trick you.
-I know. Beetle Fren.
How did you -- And old were you
when you peed your pants
on Robert De Niro's plane?
-That was really recently,
unfortunately.
[ Laughter ]
What in the world?
-That was very recently.
-Oh, my God.
Were you just --
-Well, the bathroom didn't work,
and I had to pee.
I always have to pee.
-Okay.
-I have to now because
we just played a beer game.
So I don't know what's going
to happen here, folks.
It could be exciting content
for tonight.
[ Laughter ] Anyway...
-Should I read
my two truths and a lie
and see if you can tell?
-Please.
-Okay.
I'm going to run through these.
Ready?
-Okay. No questions.
Okay. Got it.
-I stole something from the set
of the "Seinfeld" series finale.
When Big Bird was on the show,
a feather fell off of him,
and I kept the feather
and taped it
to the bottom of this desk.
-That's true.
That's true.
-You think it's true?
-I think that's true.
-I got locked in a bathroom
on a boat at a Pitbull party.
Justin Timberlake rescued me.
-Well, I've also gotten trapped
in a bathroom on a boat.
Not Pitbull's boat, but -- Hmm.
-It feels like
you're trying to trick me
with the Timber-- Oh, gosh.
It's one or three.
Oh, gosh.
What was the thing
that you stole from the set?
Oh, now you're trying
to trick me.
You're too good at this.
You know exactly
what you're doing.
-I don't remember.
It was years ago.
-You're a liar.
You know exactly what you took.
Tell me, Jimmy.
What did you take?
-I took a -- You would think
it would be, like,
cereal or something, but no.
I took a toothbrush.
-For some reason, it's so bad
so that I feel like that one
must be true,
and I feel like this one
is the lie,
because you're friends with him,
and it's a -- Uh-oh.
-You're really good.
You're correct.
Yes, I was never locked
in a bathroom ever.
[ Dinging ]
You got it.
-Okay.
-How did you --
You are very good.
-Oh, okay.
-I snuck into the "Seinfeld"
finale and I stole a toothbrush.
-I found one thing I'm good at.
-Wow. No, you're good
at a lot of things.
Musical Beers? Hello.
-Well...
-Can we tell everyone
what "Not Okay" is about?
-Yes.
"Not Okay" is about --
It's a satire about a girl
named Danni Sanders
who fakes a trip
on Instagram to Paris
to impress her co-worker.
And while she's allegedly there,
a terrorist attack happens,
and she lies
and says that she survives it.
And the unraveling of the lie
and her finding out the hard way
that the Internet
loves a takedown.
That's what it's about.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Zoey Deutch
in "Not Okay."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-Hey, mom.
Guess what.
I got invited to a writers'
retreat in Paris.
Yes, really.
No, it's not a scam.
It has a website.
Hey, guys. Crazy plot twist.
I got an e-mail today
inviting me to go on
this retreat in Paris.
I'm on my way to the airport.
♪♪
-Start with mascara.
We're gonna be
taking this concealer.
We're going go dot, dot, dot.
♪♪
-Ah! Zoey Deutch, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I just want to show you.
-We're getting the --
There it is!
-"Not Okay"
is streaming now on Hulu.
We'll be right back with a
performance from Saucy Santana.
Stick around, everybody.